a whistleblower at coca-cola has leaked
images from a sensitivity training
slideshow
that implore the audience to be quote
less white goodbye pastel polo shirts
aurevoir cucumber sandwiches penny
loafers
i think i will miss you most of all but
if woke corporations say that i need to
be less white
then dagnabbit i'm going to be less
white do i count as a white
this is a perennial question for those
of us
of sicilian more broadly southern
italian descent
were a little uh dusky as the poets used
to say you know we're a little swarthy
so are we white probably by the
standards of a
neo-nazi or some racialist probably were
not
all that white you know when italians
first came to america
uh italians were broadly considered to
be black depended on what area of the
country you were in the southern
italians were the
victims of the largest mass lynching in
american history so
you know probably i don't know not not
so white
but then by the standards of the woke
left definitely
definitely white so i suppose i'm i'm
kind of uh
caught in in the middle here and uh
regardless i'm sure coca-cola would like
me to be
less white the the company is
sort of denying that they had this
sensitivity training
i say sort of denying it because what
they're saying is
that this slide that the the
whistleblower leaked
this was not a mandatory aspect and
a lesson of the training but it was part
of the platform that coca-cola had the
employees use
so it's kind of like a denial non-denial
in any case sort of sounds like melee
math corporate talk
uh for they did it this is this is the
sort of thing they're doing
so the slides included
uh typical platitudes that you you see
today
with woke politically correct culture
confronting racism
understanding what it means to be white
challenging what it means to be racist
okay this is the kind of
bland thing we've seen before another
slide
in the u.s and other western nations
white people are socialized
to feel that they are inherently
superior because they are white
now this one i'm a little more skeptical
of
you know we don't see mandatory
corporate and university trainings
to tell people of other races how
terrible they are and how awful their
race is we don't see other races
becoming a popular and socially accepted
synonym for bad you know we don't we
don't
we don't see calls to eliminate
asian-ness
or abolish blackness or anything like
that but you do see those same calls
for whiteness so i think that second
bullet point bs and then the third one
this is the one that's really gotten
coca-cola in trouble
try to be less white
and this is the point i've made on this
show a number of times and i know a
bunch of left-wingers
who hate watch and hate listen to my
show
they do it just because they're
masochists they wanna they wanna get
their blood up in the morning or
something
they they have criticized this point
they've said michael it is crazy for you
to believe
that white and whiteness has become
a synonym in our politically correct
culture for bad
but of course it is you know when when
we analyze the history of this country
in a
more sophisticated time we would have
referred to concepts like original sin
we would have referred to the tradition
and how
certain prejudices come down the line
and that they're no good and we have to
get rid of them but because we don't
have that we don't have that moral
language anymore we don't have a
coherent moral framework everything is
blamed on white supremacy or
systemic white racism and that's why we
have to abolish
whiteness and it's it's just a stand-in
a physical stand-in
for the metaphysical concept of evil
i do want to give the these left wingers
their due here though there is some
precedent for what they're doing i
actually kind of understand the logic
which is that in in the past maybe if
you've watched old movies
you you would have heard this the word
white
was used as a synonym for good or
virtuous
so and you you more
frequently would read this in old
literature or hear this in an old movie
but you might hear the phrase
that's mighty white of you meaning you
know that's mighty good of you that's
mighty virtuous of you
and so what what the left wingers are
doing is they're not bringing the word
back to a kind of value neutrality
they're not bringing the word back to
to not connote virtue or vice what
they're doing is they're taking a word
that
in the distant past was used to mean
virtue and they're now using it to mean
vice
so how is one to be
less white let's say we take coca-cola's
challenge and demand and we say okay i'm
going to try to be less white what does
that mean well according to the
slideshow it means
to be less oppressive to be less
arrogant to be less certain
to be less defensive to be less ignorant
to be more humble to to listen to
believe to break with apathy
to break with white solidarity
wow man being white is pretty terrible
according to coca-cola but even if you
believe their description even if you
take that for what it's worth
notice how you're damned if you do and
you're damned if you don't
because all of these demands that are
being made
in the process of being less white
they're contradictory right on the one
hand they say be
less certain and then almost immediately
afterward they say believe
break with apathy how can you be less
certain and believe
to be less certain is to
[Music]
embrace a kind of radical skepticism but
then to believe and you hear this in
other kind of left-wing
public campaigns they'll say believe all
women
not weigh the evidence and you know give
women the benefit of the doubt but still
you know take them seriously no just
believe all women so
be less certain be more certain what
they're really saying is be less certain
of your views
be more certain of our views and one of
those views by the way it goes in here
is this kind of radical skepticism
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
michael knowles show to check out the
full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts